at the start of battle in his first
forum bhunivelze casts doom so be fast
about the whole thing
whatever staggers and damages the
fastest is your friend for garb soldier
of peace is a great choice for one of
them because it converts heavy / to
Artemis's arrow but I ended up going
with Nocturne equilibrium and carnival
crusher in any case you want a very list
of spells especially wind along with
heavy / for the deep damage my selection
included Aurora Aero ice Bart
flame-spark Fira and blaze ara elements
in elemental are also handy if you use
them wisely for accessories stick with
ones that guard against D faith and D
brave when God flings his site at you
make sure to guard it as quick as it
comes fling spells as fast as you can
sticking with wind when possible and
slash him to bits when he's staggered
hopefully the first form shouldn't give
you too much trouble
this is your grave
you will
[Music]
purification is now
future belongs to us
we try silver mine
Hunter
[Music]
down
your vacation
[Music]
laughs myself
in bhunivelze second form the elemental
attacks start dealing with things like
Aurora and thundera aren't so bad but
you'll need to prepare to guard
precisely against attacks like wings of
destruction
watch for bhunivelze elemental forms for
instance when he transforms with wind
spirit shoot electricity his way so
remember the paired elements wind versus
lightning and lightning versus wind fire
versus ice and ice versus fire hammer
him hard with magic when he casts
Kenneth Lee ACK him don't be sad if you
don't stagger him before he explodes
with dancing mad that you can
effectively block much of the damage if
you're really really really really
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
even if it can
yeah
you
you cannot
[Music]
[Music]
Trillian
[Music]
I will
routing care
this is your grave
[Music]
Oh
Oh God
[Music]
hang in there we're now two bhunivelze
third form in some ways it's like the
first although he's a lot more powerful
now again spell him to death arrow and
Aurora are my favorite staggering him
with some sense of expediency this is
where you're guarding abilities received
their final test given God's willingness
to throw his weapon around all
willy-nilly
as for the hypernova attack well best to
have some Expo Shinzon you that attack
is a real doozy
my flows
strikes
the beautiful
Hey
my trick
[Music]
yes
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
take this
the night flow
except
[Music]
I will win even if it killed
in decoration smartest god himself
now bhunivelze final form you're going
to want to go into it with a full EP
meter and any leftover ethers you have
the reason is because he takes almost no
damage at first you have to stagger him
and the best way to do that is to fling
spells at him as fast as you can the
best way to make that happen easily is
to use overclock and so activate
overclock as often as you can until he
is staggered
once he staggered just slash him up and
he'll go down just be careful of some of
his attacks the biggest one to keep an
eye on is heartless angel in which he
summons forth two angels that take away
almost all of your health leaving a
single HP guard as soon as the camera
focuses on lightning to block that
particular attack also be careful not to
accidentally activate army of one when
you are using overclock as long as you
overclock a lot and use ether if you
need to build up more EP you should be
okay
extinction
gorgeous
you cannot change it
you
even if it kills me
crave
you